before we go a six-year-old from Georgia  is teaching us all an important lesson  on kindness  Blake Rajan asked his mother to make him  this orange shirt that says I will be  your friend  he plans to wear it on his first day of  school today after being bullied he said  he wanted his classmates to know they  are not alone  his mom posted the picture on the  Facebook page of her small business now  hundreds of people of all ages are  asking to buy the design a powerful  reminder we should never underestimate  the power of a small gesture and the  brilliance in a small and a young ones  money to go Blake yeah and it's so many  people have a tough time at the  beginning of school because they don't  maybe they're looking for friends just  to use a lot more kindness in the world  whereas your day